цього року
відзначення голодомору як геноциду
українського народу набуло
особового значення
неозброєним оком проглядається паралелі
між Сталіним і Путіним
кровожерливим бажанням знищити українців
і чим іншим це пояснити не можна весь
час ми говорили що Сталін використовує
голуб як зброю сьогодні Путін
використовує електроенергію
нафту газ
голод як зброю не тільки проти українців
але проти всього демократичного світу
але в першу чергу проти українців бо вже
набули твердого доказу що ніяких інших
крім політичних причин голоду починаючи
з 20 сторіччя не існує
єдиним бажанням було щоб
розправитись з людьми за те що вони є
українці і зараз Путін
і на жаль Ямаш мушу констатувати що
бажання вбивати українців підтримано
більшості російського народу вбивати
українців вбивати дітей
бити породами бити по лікарням бити по
звільненому Херсону різати українців
Буча вбивати їх в театрі і на вулицях
Маріуполя вбивати на околицях Чернігова
Тростянці
рубіжному
северодонецьку в лісі чавську зараз
знищувати артилерійськими обстрілами
Бахмут ми ніколи цього не пробачимо і
наша молитва сьогодні спільно з ієрархом
українських церков нашої православної
церкви України
була заневинна закатована
і Господь цього разу з України і Україна
переможе і не зупинять нас
ніякі сталінського путінські заходи бо
ми сильні ми найкращі
Все буде добре
Слава Ісусу Христу і слава Україні
Кремлівська влада і досі не може
заспокоїтись і намагається
вбити і Підкорити українські народні але
в них нічого не вийде І сьогодні ми вже
не ті що 30 років тому навіть не ті що
були в 14-му році Зараз ми об'єдналися і
дамо відсіч кожному хто зазіхає на
цілісність і суверенітет нашої держави
кожному хто намагається вбити і катувати
українців ми ніколи цього не пробачимо і
будемо на майбутнє виховувати покоління
так щоб вони робили Україну
найкращою європейською
державою яка ніколи не повернеться на
північ
Слава Україні